hinter dieser prachtvollen Fassade
verbergen sich zwei Welten
wir sind unterwegs in Marseille in der
Hafen Metropole in der sich im Norden
der Stadt gefährliches Szenen abspielen
ist das passiert
[Musik]
unsere Reise führt uns zur Geschichten
geprägt durch Gewalt Rassismus und
Drogen in einer Stadt in der die
Kriminalitätsrate fünfmal höher ist als
an jedem anderen Ort in Frankreich
wir sind unterwegs im dritten Bezirk im
ärmstenviertel von Marseille Franzosen
die hier leben sprechen von 50 Jahren
verfehlter Migrationspolitik
es gibt viele Migranten hier alles hat
sich seit der Migration verändert die
Bevölkerung in Marseille in meinem Alter
wurde nach und nach ersetzt durch die
Einwanderer all das verursacht
Unsicherheit fördert die
Drogenkriminalität
ja das ist alles schon sehr gefährlich
diese Leute greifen auch die Polizei an
ist schon gefährlich mit all dem was
hier passiert und den Drogenhandel
wie schlimm ist das
die jungen Leute sterben sie sterben
die Geschichte von Marseille ist auch
eine Geschichte der Einwanderer
wir blicken zurück zu den Anfängen des
Ausland journals
Bilder aus dem Jahr 1973 eine Reportage
über Marseille das schon vor 50 Jahren
ein Magnet für Einwanderer war
vor allem aus Nordafrika
nach dem Algerien Krieg kamen viele
Menschen hierher
[Musik]
hier am Hafen sind die Menschen damals
angekommen ich erkenne den Leuchtturm
wieder
das Abenteuer Frankreich begann für eine
Million registrierte Araber fast immer
im Hafen von Marseille
damals kommen viele um zu arbeiten die
Bewohner von Marseille fühlen sich
verdrängt die Anfeindungen nehmen zu
das ist das Ende es gibt so viele
ja man wird hier rausgedrängt
[Musik]
notfalls müsse Gewalt angewendet werden
ich habe zu Hause zwei Gewehre die sind
bereit Zitat
sich werden in Frankreich an die 50
Algerien ermordet 17 allein in Marseille
die stolze Hafenstadt Frankreichs Tor
zum Mittelmeer 50 Jahre später wieder
eine Welle der Gewalt schon über 40 Tote
dieses Jahr ein Zusammenhang mit
Drogenkriminalität Rekord von einem
blutigen Bandenkrieg spricht
Bezirksbürgermeister silvestere geworden
in der Reportage sieht man Migranten der
ersten Generation die zum Arbeiten
gekommen sind heute sind wir bei der
dritten vierten fünften Generation und
die Einstellung ist eine ganz andere man
sollte das Problem des bestehenden
Rassismus nicht vertuschen aber heute
haben wir auch ein Respekt Problem
gegenüber der staatlichen Autorität
der Staat müsse stärker durchgreifen
fordert er die Polizei juckt macht bloß
bei Ausschreitungen wie diesen
wenn Jugendliche in den Vorstädten ihre
Wut zum Ausdruck bringen sie fordert
nicht mehr Härte sondern Hilfe sind
frustriert über Perspektivlosigkeit und
Rassismus
auch in Marseille kommt es immer wieder
zu Zusammenstößen im Kästchen noch in
den sogenannten nordvierteln von
Marseille wie 2020 als der 17-Jährige
Medi von einem Polizisten getötet wurde
wir treffen Enzo der sich noch genau
daran erinnert an die Wut auf diesen
Straßen in seiner damaligen
Nachbarschaft April
wir haben gedenkmärsche organisiert seit
2005 gab es hier sehr viele
Polizeiübergriffe das hört nicht aus
[Musik]
Künstler und hat hier früher gelebt nach
Medis Tod hat der 27-Jährige in diesem
Viertel sein allererstes Graffiti gemalt
direkt neben diesem Hauseingang wo jetzt
ganz offen meine Preisliste für Drogen
zu finden ist
das an dieser Stelle Drogen verkauft
werden ist kein Geheimnis auch nicht für
die Polizei trotzdem läuft das illegale
Geschäft irgendwie weiter
einen Verkaufsort dafür gibt die Polizei
spielt hier mit den Jungs aus der
Siedlung ein bisschen Katz und Maus
im kartja in den hochhausghettos im
Norden ließen sich über Generationen
hinweg die meisten Einwandererfamilien
nieder heute geht es als Problemviertel
40 Prozent der Anwohner sind arbeitslos
ein Ort wo bereits der junge Menschen in
die Drogenszene abfallen wo es
regelmäßig zu Banden kriegen zu
tödlichen Schießereien kommt wo Eltern
ihre Kinder beerdigen müssen
wir treffen was Ela Mutter von drei
Söhnen und zwei Töchtern
vor drei Jahren starb ihr Sohn Brahim im
Alter von 21 Jahren ein Großteil seiner
Kindheit verbrachte er im Katja noch
seler Periode das ist genau diese Zeit
die ich in meinem Leben bedauere die
Tatsache dass ich eine Wohnung im
Cartier akzeptiert habe
und ich frage mich warum ich das gemacht
habe diese Zeit hat mich wirklich sehr
sehr viel gekostet sie hat mich das
Leben meines Sohnes Brahim gekostet
Brahim habe mit Drogen nichts zu tun
gehabt doch mit einem Kumpel aus der
Drogenszene saß der Familienvater in
einem Dezemberabend im Auto am falschen
Ort zum falschen Zeitpunkt er wurde
erschossen
kurz vor seinem Tod ist dieses Foto
entstanden für was Ela eine letzte
Erinnerung an ihren Sohn
sie haben ihn getötet sie haben ihn
verbrannt sie haben mich nicht einmal
meinen Sohn sehen lassen
bis später Mama
diese Jugendlichen sind sich gar nicht
bewusst dass sie eine ganze Familie
töten ein Kind zu verlieren
auf diese Weise das ist unerträglich das
ist unmöglich
man kann sich das nicht vorstellen
super ich habe mir nie vorstellen können
dass mir so etwas einmal passiert bis
heute frage ich mich warum uns das
passiert ist
der Tod von Brahim nur einer von vielen
Frankreichs Präsident macron hat eine
Sonderkommission zur Bekämpfung der
drogennetzwerke in Marseille angeordnet
doch bis heute ist die Situation nicht
unter Kontrolle
von Terror spricht Polizist Rüdiger
an und Zielen oberhalb des Bauches des
Gegners und manchmal ziehen sie auf
Menschen die mit ihnen überhaupt nichts
zu tun haben letzte Woche hatten wir
einen Fall in Marseille eine junge Frau
im Alter von 24 Jahren die in ihrem
Zimmer vor dem Computer gearbeitet hat
wurde mit einem Kopfschuss getötet
jeden kann es hier treffen jedes Kind
jede Familie
im Sozialzentrum Laura treffen wir
Mütter aus dem Nordviertel
sie alle machen sich große Sorgen um die
Sicherheit ihrer Kinder
wenn ich meine Töchter betrachte denke
ich immer nein das ist nicht normal sie
sind immer ein wenig verängstigt und
nervös der französische Staat hilft
nicht er lässt die jungen Leute im
kartino auch einfach machen was sie
wollen weil es die schwarzen und die
Araber sind sie sind ihnen egal sollen
sie sich doch untereinander umbringen
die scheren sich einen Dreck
am späten Nachmittag holt eure Orient
ihre kleinen Kinder von der Schule ab
die zehnfache Mutter kommt aus LA majot
einer französischen Insel im Indischen
ozeanche auf keinen Fall möchte Orient
dass ihre Kinder alleine durchs Viertel
laufen und in die Hände von
Drogendealern geraten
sehr große Angst ich habe große Kinder
19 die gehen zur Uni ich habe große
Angst
[Musik]
sie hofft auf ein besseres Leben für
ihre Kinder auf eine Perspektive in
diesen sozialbausiedlungen im Norden ein
Viertel der Bevölkerung lebt unterhalb
der Armutsgrenze
viele Kinder und Enkelkinder von
Einwandererfamilien wohnen bis heute
hier
hallo wie geht's
das sind die Jugendlichen aus dem
Viertel wir sind unterwegs mit kardas
hier auch bekannt als le patron der Chef
[Musik]
du kennst sie alle
ich bin hier aufgewachsen ich bin 47
Jahre alt also kenne ich so ziemlich
jeden hier
1963 sind seine Eltern nach Frankreich
gekommen für cadere ist das Katja nore
in erster Linie Heimat und Familie doch
sein Zuhause hat sich in den letzten
Jahrzehnten deutlich verändert was sind
denn die größten Probleme für
Jugendliche hier
das Problem dass sie hier haben ist dass
sie vom Geld angezogen werden das
schnelle Geld aus dem drogennetzwerk
diejenigen die Geld brauchen werden
immer jünger und werden da hineingezogen
vom schnellen Geld sprechen hier alle
wenn 12 13-jährige Kinder bereits 50
Euro am Tag verdienen hunderte von Euro
fließen hier sogar für den
Drogentransport doch KaDeWe gegen diesen
Zustand ankämpfen mit solchen
Kunstprojekten mitten im Viertel
das Leben der Jugendlichen im Cartier
ist hart weil sie von Verbrechen
angezogen werden und wir versuchen Ihnen
den richtigen Weg zu zeigen
wir bieten Ihnen an solche Malereien
oder andere Dinge zu machen um Ihnen zu
helfen
damit sie für sich selbst eintreten
damit sie mal von hier wegkommen
der Sozialarbeiter sucht immer wieder
das Gespräch zu jungen Leuten die
Verkäuferin
ihrem eigenen Lebensumfeld nicht mehr
sicher
[Musik]
abends habe ich Angst ich arbeite im
Lebensmittelladen aber zur späten Stunde
ist niemand mehr auf der Straße keiner
geht raus früher haben wir bis 1:30 Uhr
nachts gearbeitet jetzt bin ich
gezwungen schon nachmittags zu schließen
da keine Kunden mehr kommen
Armut und Kriminalität prägen den Alltag
vieler Menschen in Marseille doch es
gibt sie die die sich nicht damit
abfinden dass sie Herkunft ihre Zukunft
bestimmt heute lebt Enzo in der
Innenstadt von Marseille der Stadt mit
den zwei Gesichtern er hat es geschafft
aus dem Problemviertel rauszukommen sich
ein neues Leben aufzubauen
seine Leidenschaft für die Kunst hat ihm
dabei geholfen seinen eigenen Weg zu
gehen
wir sind es die sich an das Leben hier
anpassen müssen
wenn wir etwas ändern wollen dann müssen
wir etwas an uns ändern in einem Wort
würde ich Marseille als meine Mutter
bezeichnen
[Musik]
wie die zweitgrößte Stadt Frankreichs
auch von vielen genannt wird ist ein Ort
der Kontraste
zwischen Drogenkriminalität und harten
Freunden kämpfen die Menschen hier
weiter für ein Leben mit mir Sicherheit
in Marseille